[Music]
what do people even do on Fridays
anymore right now it's like 5 30 just
for an espresso zero chance of going out
tonight but I'm genuinely curious what
other people are doing I guess the same
old [__] dinner bars clubs I'm not
knocking that as fun I have that Friday
energy in me right now too I just want
to go ham and do [__] but ever since I
stopped going out on Friday nights my
life's been so much better the only plan
tonight is to chill do a little work
relax wake up tomorrow feeling amazing I
can't wait
honestly
as far as those videos go that wasn't
the worst yeah I think it was like at
least it wasn't like yeah that doesn't
sound fun for me you know what's fun for
me worshiping my creator
like at least he's like hey man I'm not
knocking it it does sound like it'd be a
lot of fun but like my life's just been
better since I stopped so probably just
gonna do that I just the way he says it
it's people even do on Fridays anymore
it just sounds like there's someone
behind the camera with a gun yeah
but also it's like he said he asked the
question that he answered it yeah like
it it hasn't changed people are doing
the same thing on Fridays dinner bars
yeah yeah yeah like what do people like
what Jay yeah he doesn't eat dinner
anymore I guess dinner anymore bars I
just I I'm strictly on espresso recently
yeah life has been so much better I got
that Friday energy in me too I want to
eat some dinner but I got that Friday
and energy in me too I just want to go
out and do [__] smoke meth and [__]
go to dinner
my life has been better since you're
doing that steal [__] Copper pipings
from like a a construction site yeah
just like go ham you know just want to
go [__] ham
yeah punch them dude in the face get in
a bar fight like [__] go ham is there
really any espresso in there yeah it
looks empty as [__] you just why is he
standing like that
everything's like natural that's like
all right extra cute natural pose
he's trying to get that angle yeah
trying to get that
that 0.5 his posture is what
obtuse angles
naughty at that angle to make his hand
look as big as possible
yeah he's also holding the cup with his
knuckles yeah not with his hand yeah
like this
what a medicine is masculine energy he's
solution oriented he's never worried
about or complaining about things openly
[__] go play football
go play basketball
what are you man
you
what's the wingspan on your hand
why are you sitting at home no he's just
holding a really tiny glass oh yeah he
lives in a scale home yeah exactly 1 to
16 scale home yep masculine man is
healthy physically fit
they constantly have a growth mindset
and they're always putting themselves in
difficult situations to achieve
exceptional outcomes it's a sense of
leadership calmness and emotional
stability that allows a woman to feel
equally secure
and be pleasant in her own feminine
energy kind of like when you hear
somebody say that's my rock dude I love
the thought of people dudes that make
videos like this like
haven't spoken to a girl in like years
yeah yeah like yeah yeah all they do is
they sit in their apartment and make
videos about this is what being in your
masculine energy
he probably has but it's just a funny
thought no
no masculine energy is like when you're
all alone
you actually kind of cut off the female
connection like entirely
you know and you just kind of like focus
on yourself unwillingly yeah jerk off a
lot a lot
like
yeah
you know what's so funny to me about
this one just finished jerking off yeah
I drew this is usually how I jerk off
like this
you know it's like really funny to me
about this is when I see these like yeah
your masculine energy
there's a guy that weighs 110 pounds
with a nine inch dick that invalidates
all these things you talk about he just
shows up to a party dressed in like an
ex like an eccentric way and he just
doesn't give a [__] about anything he's
poor yeah he's like a piece of [__]
honestly freaks like cigarettes yeah
he's just like
[__] kind of sucks my boy's playing down
the way he's got a cool little grunge
band I don't really know who does grunge
anymore but it's whatever I think
they're trying to like bounce into like
a hyper pop thing anime girl's like
they're like wow what there's something
so unique about he's like yeah you're
dumb and then he leaves you're just
describing Timothy yeah yeah yeah
I hate it it's just funny like all these
I all these you know
this is what a man
and that yeah this dude's also had the
parties like he's not going to protect
you though yeah he's not going to
provide for you know with all six of
them yeah man for sure yeah he's got
Coke though so
that's bad for your body I'll find out
in five years yeah
yeah there you go young Timmy
I like to think of Timmy just being an
absolute [__] Hound in an [__] off
camera oh yes like imagine that this
roided out dude just like yipping about
being uh being a man and then Timmy just
goes like this he's like
nerd you know I used to
I used to stylize Xbox controllers
and I do reviews of them on YouTube
and even then
I was not as [__] lame as you he just
puts the cigarette on his under the
dude's kneecap
it's just no no matter what yeah any any
girl
I could get them first yeah just know
that just know that okay know that in
your heart of hearts know that
all right big boy yeah you you stay at
home on a Friday
yeah for sure whatever masculine energy
[__] are you just mad for sure bro
yeah he's just mad rude
if you stay home
who's gonna check all the IDS for all
the girls I bring into the bar
your big stupid [__] hands
you have big hands bro you know what
your hands are made for
that's what they're made for men yeah
man staying on a Friday I go out every
single night in my life [__] rules
I could also stay in every night in my
life still would be so much better than
yours
and you're probably gonna tell yourself
like you're gonna die at 50. I probably
will and I'm gonna die having a
threesome so
with your mom and your sister yeah
you're gonna die at 70.
with the same girl
[__] I was in Dune okay
you wanna talk about masculine energy
you know it's pretty masculine when the
whole [__] set is like oh
[Music]
On My Knob
and I don't even care
you know what's pretty masculine
everyone wants to blow me the second I
walk on set
regardless of preference I could [__]
your dad
okay
so save it miss me with that I [__]
Army Hammer
[Laughter]
yeah
Offset you see he pretended to [__] me
on camera and I didn't like that
so I gamed him up I raised him up took
him back to my trailer I put his [__]
ankles by his head and I boned the [__]
out of him and he loved it
[__] him so hard he came on himself
how's that sound
and after he nutted on his own chest I
said call me by your name
and he goes Army and I'm like that's
right
I left
his wife is texting me now that they're
divorced can you imagine that